wie reich sind sie denn im Internet
steht 1,4 Milliarden ja quatsch totaler
Blitz da steht dies sein der reichste
Kölner ja das bin ich vielleicht
tatsächlich aber es dürften ja schon wir
haben ja die Häuser in Berlin z.B
gesehen mehrere hundert Millionen seind
das ist richtig schon richtig 50% der
deutschen also die ärmere Hälfte besitzt
was glauben Sie wie viel Prozent des
Gesamtvermögens das ist ich kenne dir
diese Statistiken 1,4% ja ja klar und
wenn die jetzt 20% kriegen was passiert
dann haben Sie 20% meh Konsum das ist
kurze Blase na ja sie haben ein bisschen
mehr Sicherheit im Leben wenn die das
entsprch wenn die das entsprechend
entsprechend tatsächlich in dieser
Richtung benutzen würden dann haben sie
recht tun sie das weiß ich nicht aber
das klingt jetzt so als würden die Leute
mit dem Geld nicht umgehen können ich
sorge dafür dass gewisse Sachen
passieren wenn das Geld verteilt wird
wird es nicht investiert wird ausgegeben